MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
WE TRAVELED TO THE TEXAS
BORDER LAST WEEK FOR THE
THIRD TIME IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS AND I WAS ABLE
TO SEE FIRSTHAND HOW
THIS CRISIS HAS EXPANDED
THROUGHOUT TEXAS.
FROM EL PASO TO MCALLEN
TO DEL RIO AND NOW
BORDER AGENTS TELL ME
MIGRANTS ARE EXPANDING
INTO ARIZONA.
WATCH IT.
>> JUST BETWEEN
SEPTEMBER 19, AND A
SEPTEMBER 25, WE HAD
OVER 5000, 5400 ARRESTS
IN A VERY SMALL SECTOR.
THIS IS NOT A BIG AREA.
MARIA: HE’S REFERRING TO HUMAN
ARIZONA AND JOIN ME RIGHT NOW
THE MAN WHO IS FIGHTING TO STOP
THIS SURGE TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT.
GOVERNOR, GREAT TO SEE
IN THIS IS MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
BEFORE WE GET TO WHAT
YOUR ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING TO STOP ALL OF
THIS, ASSESS WHERE WE
ARE.
ARE YOU SEEING THIS
CRISIS EXPAND BEYOND
WHAT WE SAW A YEAR AGO?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LISTEN, A YEAR AGO, OF
COURSE, WAS STILL DURING
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND THEY HAD PUT IN
PLACE THE POLICIES THAT
LED IT TO THE GREATEST
REDUCTION IN BORDER
CROSSINGS, BUT NOW, WE
ARE SEEING THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF ORDER CROSSING
BECAUSE OF THE
CATASTROPHIC OPEN BORDER
POLICIES BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND WE
ARE SEEING MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE COME IN, BUT I
HAVE TO TELL YOU THERE’S
SOMETHING GETTING EVEN
WORSE AND THAT’S THE
CARTELS ARE GETTING EVEN
MORE AGGRESSIVE AND THE
CARTELS ON THE MEXICAN
SIDE OF THE BORDER ARE
BEGINNING TO OPEN FIRE
ON THE NATIONAL GUARD
THAT TEXAS HAS DOWN ON
THE BORDER TO SECURE THE
BORDER.
THIS IS ESCALATING INTO
A FIRING MORE ON EACH
SIDE OF THE BORDER WHERE
TEXAS AND AIR NATIONAL
GUARD ARE HAVING TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES AND
THE FED THE STATE OF
TEXAS-- DEFENDED THAT
STATE OF TEXAS.
MARIA: TO BE CLEAR, WE WERE IN
DEL RIO AND YOU SAID IT’S
GETTING WORSE IN OTHER AREAS OF
TEXAS?
>> EVERYONE SAW WHAT
HAPPENED IN DEL RIO WITH
REGARD TO THE HAITIANS
THAT CAME IN THERE, BUT
RIGHT NOW THE HOTTEST
POINT IS IN ROMA, TEXAS,
IN THE STARK COUNTY AREA
AND THAT’S THE AREA
WHERE THE CARTELS ON THE
MEXICAN SIDE OF THE
BORDER ARE SHOOTING AT
THE NATIONAL GUARD ON
THE TEXAS SIDE OF THE
BORDER.
WHAT TEXAS HAS TO DO IS
TO STEP UP AND GUARD
MULTIPLE POINTS ACROSS
THE ENTIRE BORDER.
MARIA: UNBELIEVABLE, AND I KNOW
THE MEXICAN CARTEL ARE VERY
SMART AND THEY KNOW HOW TO FLOOD
ONE AREA SO IT OPENS UP ANOTHER
AREA SO THEY CAN GET THROUGH
SMUGGLING HUMANS AND DRUGS
ACROSS.
WE HAVE NEW UNOFFICIAL
NUMBERS FROM ONE OF OUR
BORDER SOURCES THAT SAYS
IN THE LAST MONTH WE SAW
187,000 APPREHENSIONS,
BUT OF COURSE, THE
NUMBER OF GOT A WAYS IS
HIGHER.
42,649 DOCTOR WASTE, 91
PEOPLE DIED IN THE U.S.
IN THE DESERT.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SAY
ABOUT THESE GOT A WAYS,
WE JUST HEARD SOME
RANCHERS THAT SAID THEY
ARE WATCHING THEIR
PROPERTY DAMAGE EVERY
DAY AND THEY HAVE TO
CARRY THEIR GUNS
EVERYWHERE THEY GO
INCLUDING TO THROW AWAY
THE TRASH.
>> THOSE RANCHERS WERE
SPOT ON IN THEIR
ASSESSMENT AND THAT IS
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS COMPLETELY ABANDONED
THOSE RANCHERS.
IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS
ABANDONED ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO LIVE ON THE BORDER.
THEY HAVE ABANDONED
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS AND THESE ARE
COUNTIES AND PEOPLE WHO
TRADITIONALLY HAVE VOTED
DEMOCRAT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS IGNORING THEM PUTTING
THEM IN DANGER AND YOU
HEARD THAT RANCHERS TALK
ABOUT THE NEED TO CARRY
A GUN, REMEMBER BIDEN
SAID THERE IS NO NEED
FOR ANYONE TO EVER HAVE
A GUN, SIX ROUNDS
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY
BE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
NEED THE FIREPOWER TO BE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH THE
CARTELS WHO MAY BE
COMING ACROSS THE
BORDERS OF THIS IS
EXACTLY WHY PEOPLE NEED
THEIR SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS TO PROTECTED
THEIR OWN SAFETY AND
DEFEND THEMSELVES ON THE
BORDER.
IT’S ALSO EXACTLY WHY
TEXAS IS DOING MORE THAN
ANY STATE IS EVER DONE
TO SECURE THIS REGION SO
WE CAN HELP RANCHERS
LIKE THAT, IT’S WHY
TEXAS HAS DEVOTED MORE
THAN $3 BILLION TO
SECURE THE BORDER AND
IT’S WHY WE HAVE THE
NATIONAL GUARD AND THE
TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY ON THE
BORDER, ITS WHY TEXAS
ITSELF IS BUILDING A
BORDER WALL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
BETTER SECURE OUR
BORDERS.
MARIA: HOW CAN YOU DO THAT, I
MEAN, YOU ARE DOING THAT JUST ON
STATE LAND I KNOW BECAUSE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION LAST WEEK
SAID IT’S CANCELING ALL THE
REMAINING BORDER WALL
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS IN THAT
AREA, SO I WAS THERE WITNESSING
LAWS THAT WERE HALF DONE AND THE
OTHER HALF IS WIDE OPEN, I MEAN,
IT’S QUITE EASY TO JUST GET--
JUST COMING FROM THE RIO GRANDE,
JUMP OVER AND GET IN A GOT AWAY
CAR AND I WANT TO POINT OUT WE
UNDERSTAND-- ANOTHER THING I
LEARNED LAST WEEK IS THAT THESE
GETAWAY CARS ARE DRIVEN BY
AMERICANS, SO THE CARTELS ARE
ADVERTISING THEIR SERVICES ON
TIKTOK AND SNAPCHAT I’M TOLD SO
LOOK AT THIS GRAPHIC WHERE WE
SHOW CARTELS CHARGING THE
MIGRANTS FROM THE NORTHERN
TRIBAL EIGHT TO $10,000 BUT THEN
THEY ARE PAYING AMERICAN
CITIZENS A THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
BE THE GETAWAY CAR AND 90% OF
THE CARS STOPPED WITH ILLEGALS
ARE DRIVEN BY AMERICANS.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL
IT’S TRUE.
A SECOND, IT’S SOMETHING
THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY HAS BEEN
WORKING ON AND WE JUST
MADE IT FAR EASIER FOR
THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY TO TELL
THE REST AND BE ABLE TO
PROSECUTE THESE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ASSISTING IN
SMUGGLING.
THIS IS AN ACCOMPLICE TO
A TELL-- FELONY IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS AND SO I
SIGNED A NEW LAW MAKING
IT EASIER TO CRACKDOWN
ON SMUGGLERS IN TEXAS
AND WE ARE GOING AFTER
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESPONDING TO THESE
TIKTOK REQUESTS WHO ARE
ASSISTING THE CARTELS
AND SMUGGLING PEOPLE
INTO THE U.S.
THAT IS A CRIME AND WE
LOOKED UP AT THESE
PEOPLE BEHIND BARS.
MARIA: JUST EXTRAORDINARY.
GOVERNOR, I WANT TO
SWITCH GEARS AND ASKED
BEFORE YOU GO ABOUT
THESE AXING MANDATES.
TEXAS AND FLORIDA
BANNING FLOOR-- COVID
VACCINE MANDATES IN THE
WHITE HOUSE IS ACCUSING
YOU OF PUTTING POLITICS
AHEAD OF HEALTH.
WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO
BAN IT AND SET THE
RECORD STRAIGHT FOR US,
DOES FEDERAL LAW
OVERRIDE STATE LAW ON
WHAT YOU CAN DO WITH
REGARD TO MANDATING A
VACCINE?
LOOK AT ALL OF THE
PEOPLE RESIGNING RIGHT
NOW.
>> WELL, YOU MAKE A GOOD
POINT ABOUT THE PEOPLE
RESIGNING BECAUSE THAT’S
ONE PROBLEM WITH REGARD
TO THE SUPPLY CHAIN
BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE
BEING FORCED TO GET A
VACCINE DON’T WANT TO DO
THAT HENCE THEY ARE
LEAVING THEIR JOBS, BUT
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION,
CLEARLY WHAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS DOING IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THERE’S A ZERO AUTHORITY
IN THE CONSTITUTION THAT
GIVES THE PRESIDENT OR
HIS ADMINISTRATION THE
AUTHORITY TO MANDATE
ANYONE TAKE A VACCINE
AND THAT’S WHY WE FEEL
VERY CONFIDENT THAT
THESE ESTATE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS SUPERSEDE THE
FEDERAL EXECUTIVE ORDER
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
EXECUTIVE ORDER IS
COMPLETELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR FELLOW TEXANS
WHO HAVE BEEN FORCED
INTO THIS IMPOSSIBLE
SITUATION ABOUT
PROVIDING FOR THEIR
LIVELIHOOD VERSUS THAT
BEING FORCED TO TAKE
INTO THEIR BODY
SOMETHING THEY DO NOT
WANT THAT IT WILL BE THE
STATE STEPPING UP AND
PROTECTING THE
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY OF
OUR FELLOW TEXANS FROM
BEING FORCED TO TAKE A
VACCINE THAT COULD CAUSE
THEM HARM, THAT DOESN’T
TAKE INTO EFFECT THE
PRIOR IMMUNITY THEY MAY
OTHERWISE HAVE, DOESN’T
TAKE INTO EFFECT AT THE
SEVERE REACTIONS THAT
SOME PEOPLE ARE HAVING
TO THE SHOT.
I HAVE TO RAISE WITH YOU
SOMETHING ELSE PEOPLE
HAVING CONSIDERED AND
THAT IS WHERE DOES THIS
END?
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
FEDERAL MANDATE FOR A
SHOT.
AS YOU KNOW THERE’S
WANING EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE SHOT.
ARE PEOPLE REQUIRED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO TAKE A SHOT EVERY
SINGLE YEAR FOR THE REST
OF THEIR LIFE?
AMERICANS NEED TO COME
TO GRIPS WITH THE
OVERREACH BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
MARIA: IT’S AN ISSUE AND A POINT
THAT IS WELL TAKEN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THAT AND
THAT’S WHY WE SEE ALL
THESE RESIGNATIONS FROM
NURSES AND MILITARY.
THAT’S GOING TO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY AS
WELL BECAUSE ALREADY
BUSINESSES CAN HIRE THE
PEOPLE MAY NEED.